it's an authorized version of the pool
Drake show or psycho Rickshaw in Sudan
they call it traksha mostly imported
from India and China the small vehicle
has invaded the streets of Sudan
especially in the last few years
and since the War Began in April
Direction has gained even more
popularity
it's quick and comfortable and it's also
cheap
it's light and easy and safe so we like
it really
I have a large family and the jobs that
I do don't bring sufficient income so I
decided to buy a rickshaw which I'll use
not only to make additional money but
also to use my family rides such as
taking children to school this
government employee hasn't received his
salary since April and says Direction
brings him up to twenty dollars a day
filling a huge gap in his income he
estimated that at least 3 000 other
public employees in Port Sudan use the
same means to survive
this man is one of the most popular
figures in town keeping directions
running from his garage
I was a car repair mechanic then I
purchased the Rickshaw and started to
learn how it functions and for 20 years
I've been doing this job which I really
love I noticed an increase in Rickshaw
since the war started many have brought
their rickshaws from Khartoum
by the way when Yusuf isn't around most
drivers refused to let his boys fix
their vehicles they say only he has the
Magic Touch they also love him because
he often doesn't ask for a set price
if they put any amount in his pocket he
doesn't even check it
I've known Yusuf since 2001. he's the
best mechanic in the Red Sea State he's
the king of the Rickshaw and he helps
everyone
a world away from the likes of uber
young man created WhatsApp groups to
organize at extra service coordinating
between drivers and clients
the idea is to help people we made sure
to keep the price of the ride low and
clients feel safe because we know the
name of the driver they're going with
so far so good for raksha users
but with inflation soaring and the
conflict intensifying even this
temporary solution may not last for many
Muhammad van al-jazeera Paul Sudan